[Music]
cindy mccain is a lifelong republican
who controversially supported joe biden
in the presidential election campaign
the wife of the late john mccain the
republican presidential candidate who
lost to barack obama
now believes her parties at a historic
crossroads
our party as a whole has lost its way i
believe now that
i know there's many many people now that
want to see a different kind of
republican party
um and i believe this party may split
in the aftermath of a hostile and highly
charged election
her hope is that republicans and
democrats can forge a new era of
cooperation
for the good of america cindy mccain
welcome to the economist asks thank you
i'm happy to be here
you were one of the lucky few in an
event that
had to be limited for obvious reasons
who were there to see president joe
biden into office
what was the standout moment
for you and how different did it feel to
previous inaugurations
well you know really two moments number
one of course the inauguration of joe
biden
and the abs the absolute meaning of what
it was all about it actually brought
tears to my eyes because
i view this as a new beginning a new
time for the united states of america
and certainly something that's going to
uh going to
now be an inclusive government and one
that
believes in its people and and not a
government that's for its own personal
profit or own personal gain
so for me it stood for many things and
of course the second one was the
inauguration of kamala harris will make
an amazing
uh vice president and of course is
that's
also a new beginning for the united
states having a female in that position
finally it was something that was that
made all of us
uh reminded all of us about what is
great about america
two weeks ago uh our capital was under
siege
and two weeks later here we are a
peaceful transfer of power
and and a new beginning for the united
states president biden made that
inauguration speech standing on the same
soil
as the riots two weeks ago that you
referenced that was the 6th of january
written now into the history of the
senate yeah
politics yes i mean yeah well
you you still sound you sound moved by
that by your response
that i could not believe what was
happening and i could not believe
not only what was happening but the
disrespect
towards the bodies and the meaning the
bodies of the senate and the house
and the disrespect for the actual the
actual chambers themselves i mean
i looked down with t and watched with
tears in my eyes people
mistreating the desks and and the items
that were in the desk and talking about
the members of the senate like somehow
they were comedic players
uh it's this is not comedy and what they
did was illegal
and it was wrong and it was instigated
by the
by the former president and so i as you
can see democracy works
democracy worked for us uh yes democracy
can be flawed but it in
our case it worked and we are back on
track we are going to
work together as a government in a
bipartisan fashion because that's what
joe biden believes in and works works
for
now of your fellow republicans you're
still a member of the republican
party yes i am well by
a margin a small margin but still a
margin 45
to 43 percent of them respectively
said that they supported the actions of
those pro-trump
extremists this was from a yougov survey
reported in
the economists of a reliable source what
does it tell you
i think it tells me that that a lot of
uh that our party as a whole has lost
its way
uh we were the party i you know i was
i'm old enough to have been a member of
the party when ronald reagan was
president
and we at that particular point in time
we were the party of inclusion we were
the party of new beginnings we were the
party
of working together and we've lost our
way
we have not only have we lost our way
but we have have lost what we really
stand for and what we we believed in for
many many years
but that has a great deal to do with the
actions at the top
so i believe now that i know there's
many many people now that want to see
a different kind of republican party um
and i believe
this party may split i don't know what's
going to happen with it but i
i know that we can't move forward in the
fashion that we be
that these people behaved in on january
6th
and so i believe i truly believe
something's going to give
within our republican party to hopefully
bring it back to where we were in the
center and
the party of new new beliefs and new
beginnings
and you how do you feel about your your
own arizona
gop criticizing you i think they're
proposing to send you for your support
of joe biden
that seems to cause some mirth i find it
comical
i really do in fact we've talked about
having t-shirts made so
listen i'm a republican i did what i
thought was the right thing for my
country i'm very proud of what i did
and and i have absolutely i look back
and i know i know
i did the right thing as far as the
arizona gop
they'll do what they do and and my life
will go on
and yet you said you won't leave the
republican party if i'm still reading
you
correctly but when you saw that violence
in the senate when you saw members of
your party
rioting in the heart of the capital and
of american democracy and those images
going around the world
did the thought cross your mind i need
to get out of this party
never it's never across my mind
i guess sure have i been frustrated yes
sure have i
ever had moments where i thought i can't
believe what i'm seeing what
what the heck is going on uh who are
these people you know they're not my
they're not my
republicans uh which which makes it even
more important that those of us who are
law abiding citizens
and and do not believe in the kind of
chaos that took place
uh make sure that our party our party
finds its way again
and finds the center of where we belong
and and i believe there's enough people
out there that are going to
do just that i spoke to your late
husband in
april 2017 and senator mccain
gave yes indeed i mean i look back on it
very funny and of course with
great sadness like many people who knew
him and loved a good old political
tussle because he
he was up for that wasn't he yes he was
he loved a good political tussle john
mccain was a person who
uh he's he believed what he believed and
he lived what he believed
and uh he would fight like cats and dogs
with with the opposition on
on the floor of the senate but but it
was never personal they would walk off
the floor
uh grass barns have dinner together grab
a drink together whatever it may be
that's what true leadership is about
it's not personal
and so that's the difference in in the
john mccains and the ted kennedy's of
the world
as to as opposed to what some of the
people that we
have right now that are in the senate in
the house he said to me this
partisanship is at an all-time high and
he conceded obviously americans are not
very happy
with business as it's conducted here
in our nation's capital now doesn't that
encapsulate
the challenge here also for president
biden four decades in public office
he's a man of the system he understands
the system that's also how
bipartisanship
works but he does now lead a country
whose basic beliefs
seem to be that the system is broken and
hasn't been working for them
i believe that i believe because the
partisanship
is and and was certainly at an all-time
high as my husband
said we also now have a president that
is willing to step across the aisle
work together talk it out figure out
what's best for the country not what's
best for the party
and move forward and and joe biden's the
perfect person for this
because all of us have seen him in
action we know what he can do we know
what he's capable of
he's already called a meeting of the
leadership of both parties to come to
the white house
and begin talking about these issues
things that face the country we're
swamped with corona virus we have to get
this under control
and and make sure that we have a plan
and
that's our i know that that's his first
and foremost
uh item that he needs to get to and but
he's willing
he is willing to and needs to and is
going to bring the leadership together
so that we can work together for the
good of the country
is america looking strong now after
everything we've seen in that very
fraught and contested election and we
really cannot
believe aside that many many people a
very large number of americans
did not want to let go of donald trump
or what he stood for
i think we're going to see the world as
you saw there was an outpouring from the
world community
because they want the united states of
america to stay strong
and and be the beacon of hope that we've
always been
and so so it's uh in my opinion i think
that with
with president biden we're going to see
just that
a world that is is uh hopefully better
and hopefully hopefully the united
states stands up to the thugs in the
world
and not not cow towed to them and and
most importantly be be the the nation of
of hope and
and and honor that we've always been uh
i believe in that i believe joe biden
can re
re redo you know reconstitute that for
us and also help us
uh remind the world that you know even
though our democracy is flawed it's
still the best we've got and
we're strong as ever you can listen to
the full interview on our podcast
the economist asks every week we publish
a conversation we've had
with a high profile figure click the
link opposite
to enjoy it and thanks for watching
you